it's time we had the talk not about the
birds and the bees but the scammers and
the fees
guys today we're taking a look at the
phenomenon known as the dogetuber okay
the dogetuber
they're a strange species a
subclassification
of the family of scammers and the
specific genus
is financial shills but it's even more
specific than that
the doge tuber lacks empathy heart and
any morality
at all it masquerades as a genuine
analyst for crypto but in actuality it
only has one analysis
in its arsenal to the moon buy now get
rich
420 dogecoin elon musk discord buy the
the signals now
the dogetuber is full of enthusiasm but
they lack any
moral empathy for people getting wrecked
by their advice
they only care about their own profits
which they get
by constantly evangelizing about the
latest crypto that they're holding or
they're getting paid to promote and look
the reason i'm making this video
is because crypto's in the news right
now and doge troopers can be highly
deadly to your portfolio's health and i
want to make sure
you're as educated as possible because
it's my advice
that you stay away from these people but
they can be hard to spot
which is why i'm gonna be giving you
four symptoms
someone you know could be a doge tuber
no really
this is a real thing look they're hard
to spot like i said they can look like
they're just
enthusiastic about crypto but there's
key differences so number one what does
the dogetuber do
those tubers they give investment advice
while pretending to not be giving you
investment advice and look you may have
seen this disclaimer in a hundred
youtubers bios i am not a financial
advisor and this
is not financial advice it's for all and
entertainment purposes do your own
research at diligence
before buying stocks and crypto blah
blah blah look this is a normal legal
disclaimer people have to use
it's like when a lawyer who's not your
lawyer says this is not legal advice but
doge troopers use this as
camouflage as cover as a loophole to
sort of willy wonka their way out of
legal liability because what they'll do
is they'll portray themselves as an
expert
then they'll give you financial advice
sprinkle a little fairy dust i'm not
giving you financial advice and they
somehow absolve themselves which means
that if you get wrecked it's all on you
they're not gonna take any
responsibility
and to be clear not everyone who has
this disclaimer who's like educating you
on how to analyze stocks
is a problem they're not doge troopers
right if a finance youtuber is teaching
you how to evaluate stocks
that's not financial advice they're
teaching you sort of how to do the thing
what is different is if someone gives
you financial advice they say hey go buy
this
go buy that how is that not financial
advice they're telling you hey you want
to get rich like me
go buy this that's financial advice you
can't then say
i'm not a financial advice this is all
entertainment if you're telling people
what to do now for this next tip we got
to go to the board
so the next tip is that doge tubers are
constantly shilling some dogecoin that
they've been paid to promote so this
combined with part one is what makes the
dogetuber so deadly
by pretending to be an expert saying
that they're not giving you financial
advice but giving you financial advice
they can enrich themselves while making
you poor so these people they're not
gonna tell you what their position is in
these cryptos
they're not gonna tell you that they got
paid but nonetheless they will promote
these things
to the moon telling you that they're the
next big thing but not telling you that
they're gonna make a killing on it
here's what one of these dogetubers
looks like
on twitter it's a sam pepper by the way
he's famous for like
faking a prank where he killed his
friend or something i don't know
they say this coin is bound to go up
interesting might be five to ten minutes
late announcing info
and then they say i'm really excited to
be promoting and hyping this new coin
by the amazing team at rootkit finance
they're telling you oh it's gonna be so
great huge growth
it's going to the moon it's going up the
project keeps expanding blah blah blah
truly amazing project and at the very
bottom
not financial advice once again we see
the dogetuber's classic
note but the key thing here is that it's
not just one thing he's constantly
shilling altcoins that's what he does on
his twitter account now the next feature
of a doge tuber
is that they're never negative this is a
key thing they're always bullish there's
no money
in uh bad news there's no money in real
analysis which sometimes includes you
know like
the truth like the coin sucks right
instead they replace
analysis with words like get rich to the
moon
and pumping now look let me be clear the
doge tuber is not the same thing as a
crypto
enthusiast who also kind of sounds like
that sometimes
because here's the deal i'm not gonna
get mad and no one's gonna get mad about
people getting excited that they put 500
into dogecoin two years ago and they saw
it go to a thousand
or a hundred thousand dollars i'm like
i'm happy for you dude i wish that was
me
but the difference is this the doge
tuber isn't excited about their
portfolio
they want to get you excited so you buy
in
and then make their portfolio go up
right that's the real intention behind
it all
this is what makes them so slimy is
because they say they're trying to do
one thing which is this i'm just a
crypto analyst baby just
analyzing these sweet cryptos when
actually they're just shilling it
and they're just salesmen right which
brings us to number four
the dogetuber used to be thought of
among ecologists among
cryptologists as being a relative of the
analyst
a weird you know offshoot a genetic
mishap but the truth is
is that according to new research coming
out in the journal nature the doge tuber
is
actually a relative of the salesman
because even though they might provide
some analysis or some like facts about a
coin
they're only doing that to give you the
good news and they'll never give you the
bad news which is more like a salesman
right like you go to a car
lot they're going to tell you it goes
zero to 60 in like four seconds
they're gonna tell you you know what the
price is how great everything is
what they're not gonna tell you is that
it's been in like four wrecks and the
transmission's gone in two weeks right
they never show you the bad side of it
which makes them different from an
analyst
and it's all of these four things right
giving advice pretending not to be
giving advice
constantly shilling things that they
have a stake in and they're not telling
you they have a stake in they're always
giving you super bullish price
projections saying it's going to the
moon
and of course the last one which is
their salesman not actual analysts
the four of these is what identifies the
doge tuber scumbag
and here's where i want to introduce you
to a doge trooper to give you an idea
of what all four of these together look
like
this is miles g investments and it only
takes a single look at this guy's page
to understand what's going on here
dogecoin breaking news huge moves rocket
dogecoin two dollars dogecoin get rich
tonight
or one of my personal favorites dogecoin
will make you rich
tomorrow for 21 that was the day
dogecoin actually
that of pumping crashed to say that this
is irresponsible
is the understatement of the century
you're sending hundreds of thousands of
people
constant sales pitches for dogecoin
making them rich and no amount
of saying well i'm not an investor i'm
not financial advisor when you say
miles g investments no amount of that is
gonna absolve you of this responsibility
i don't even care if it's like a legal
thing like
hey legally he covered his bases you're
a douche like
you're a bad person if you do this to
followers because no matter what you say
they're gonna follow you right they're
gonna look at your headlines
they're gonna look at your titles and
yeah you might say that i'm just
playing the crypto game right i just
have to do what i have to do
but when you're doing this and you're
telling people they're gonna get rich
tonight
they're gonna go in a lot of them are
gonna get wrecked
and what are you gonna do nothing you're
gonna say well it wasn't my fault
these people are a blight on the crypto
community i hate to say it
and it's look it's not up to me to you
know grandstand and say they should be
taken off the platform you guys know
i'm not a fan of anyone getting deep
platforms instead i hope these people
just reflect on what they're doing and
they're like hey this is bad
right it's not just this guy by the way
i'm picking on him specifically that's
why it's an entire classification it's
the doge tuber this is what they do
they feed on other people's portfolios
in order to make themselves rich
and they feel no kind of problem with
just blatantly shilling things
and telling them they're gonna get rich
while full well knowing that this is a
super risky investment by the way the
irony is not lost on me that i got my
channel deleted for one video on
dogecoin where i was like saying people
should be responsible
and that this guy is like shilling a
bunch of coins every single day
and his channel's allowed to stay up but
whatever and look at the end of the day
these people aren't going anywhere i'm
sure miles g will probably continue to
make his videos
i'm sure doge tubers will continue to
make their videos right um
across the spectrum it's not just about
doge it's about any kind of
shilling of some cryptocurrency with
ulterior motives but you have to
remember
that they are not analysts they're
salesmen and they're trying
to sell you a bill of goods often a bad
one
so i don't think there's anything to be
done about them i think
you the viewer have to recognize it for
what it is
and stay away for your portfolio's
health or you could just learn the
lesson the hard way
and uh get burned eventually but i'd
rather tell you guys
help you out help you save your money
sorry that's basically it i hope you
enjoyed this taxonomic look
at doge tubers now you can spot them for
yourselves
and save yourself and your family from
the dogetuber
that may be near you thanks for watching
i appreciate you
see you in the next
that was where you one me wake up and
smell the coffee